on you know we're we got to talk about
the political ramifications for the jury
and these new riots and what's causing
them
we got the story from nbc news
ex-officer kim potter charged with
second-degree manslaughter in dante
wright case
potter a 26 year old 26-year brooklyn
center
minnesota police veteran shot and killed
dante wright during a traffic stop
sunday
i think at this point we all know for
the most part what the story is
this guy dante wright had a felony
warrant for aggravated robbery he was at
a party
spent the night woke up approached a
woman who had cash
threatened he flashed his gun at her and
said give me the money and he threatened
her and she said no
they fled she called the cops he got a
warrant they pulled him over for expired
tags
his plates were expired that's a
legitimate stop they they take him out
they cuff him
the cop is on the body camera saying
don't do it don't run don't run
stop stop stop and then he fights jumps
in the car
lady cop pulls out her gun and she yells
taser taser taser they jump out of the
way and she shoots him
and then she goes holy s i just shot him
now she's being charged these extremists
have published her home information or
address
so the cops have built erected
barricades around her house because
they're expecting riots
i guess the challenge here is i mean
what do we even say about this happening
again
another look police shootings will
happen yeah they will always happen
until the police develop you know get
get until we develop telekinesis
you know gloves that the police can just
put their hand up and the person freezes
there's going to be lethal force until
the social worker puts their hand up and
the person freezing right if
only there was a licensed clinical uh
social worker there the jedi all the
time who could have just
calmed everyone down without their
feelings
just walk right into jail yeah the
social worker would have
seen dante and when they said stop don't
run
they would have been like wait a minute
stop
don't run i didn't think about it like
that
or if everybody's hand behind his back
and they walk with the squad car and
it's all over exactly that's it
or if they really want to play with his
head they're like don't stop run
and he doesn't do it the cops employ
reverse psychology
that's what a degree gets it's
sad because it's sad because obviously
this is going to continue to happen
right police officers have to use lethal
force just given the nature of their
line of work
and sometimes it's not going to be
justified and sometimes it is going to
be justified but either way it's going
to be treated by the dominant media
culture as if it's not justified and
these kinds of things are going to
happen we're going to keep burning our
country down
i don't know i'm generally saying like i
have no idea what the solution is i
don't know where we go from here it's
frightening you ever see those videos
where they have
uh it's a it's a big gun and when it
fires it's a bunch of weights
in in a circle with a big net behind it
and it
spreads out and it catches all the
pigeons yeah
i'm i'm half kidding but i'm wondering
if uh you know the real solution is
i wouldn't even call reform but a change
in police tactics and how you deal with
a stop like this so what happened was
they got him out of the car but they
were holding him right next to the
driver's seat
so when he ripped away and jumped into
the driver's seat they could have got
him out and immediately pulled him back
and pulled him far
back i know it's easy to be like i
wasn't there but here's what i would
have done
but i'm wondering if there's like if if
we can look at how police behave
you know instinctively and then come up
with a simple training plan or procedure
plan
that can put a roadblock in a lot of
these circumstances
like face the guy backwards immediately
you know or or like
put his left make his left leg over his
right leg or something like that that
could just
make it very difficult for them to get
the jump on a cop in some way
it's not easy you know yeah cuff their
feet right away there you go there's a
tendency for
people to take advantage of like things
they see that they didn't real like it's
like don't leave your backpack in your
back seat in plain view
because if someone walks by they're way
more likely to break into your car if
they see something that is so
misogynistic of you to say dude
she can wear whatever dress she wants
wherever she goes at any time boy that's
a good point but don't tempt fate
i guess is the point nope misogyny this
is what's this is what's
interesting about uh what tim just said
too though i mean there are what four
million police interactions per year
and the number of people killed by
police officers shot by police
police officers is like usually under a
thousand usually
in the hundreds and so it's extremely
rare
and so my point is even if they change
their tactics to minimize the number of
deaths there are still going to be some
deaths
right and there are still going to be
riots as there is takes only one you
know if everybody just took a ged
stats class oh sorry with this i
shortened it up i thought it just it's
totally neutered we know what you're
saying i totally neutered i thought he
crossed himself as i as i sent me
blasphemy
it was i tried to use acronyms i'm sorry
if everybody would just take a gash darn
which is what i meant in the first place
well then maybe we could put all the
stuff in perspective yes
agreed i got a question about this when
she yelled taser taser taser was she
ordering the other cop to fire their
taser and she was just holding her gun
waiting she hasn't i don't think she
said yet and that's smart
but the department said she they thought
she was
intending to use her taser intending to
use her taser but then
grabbed her gun instead that was stupid
because
most people look at this and i think a
reasonable person sees this here's a guy
who's wanted an aggravated robbery
he's been known to have a ruger 45 in
the past he resisted arrest attempted to
flee and then jumped into his car
and they couldn't see what he was
reaching for at that point shooting him
was justified
i think so too you couldn't see me
turned away and he like looked like he's
reaching into the passenger seat or
something and why
exactly i don't understand why what what
do they think's gonna happen it's like
i'm gonna get away from this cop and
then a week later i'll go to jail for
for 10 more years
like what do they think is gonna happen
the same thing that leads them to commit
these crimes is the same thing that
leads them to do these dumb things in
the presence of cops
poor impulse control total stupidity
sheer lunacy bad education no father
no community all these systemic issues
well this guy had a dad
he was this guy had a dad well he had a
suck ass dad then apparently who didn't
without no no no no i wasn't i wasn't
that wasn't directed at you that wasn't
directed at you i was just saying a
prayer for the guy
oh but i can't say a prayer for him but
at the same time like i'm trying to
acknowledge that this is a systemic
oh no why 100 agree with you right
there's a huge system that breathes
something like this
where somebody doesn't know that you
don't carry gun you don't commit crimes
you don't commit aggravated assault you
don't try to flee from a cop and you
sure as heck
don't put your hand down on the floor
boards when the cop has a gun drawn on
exactly no but nobody understands when
there it's because people make this out
about systemic racism but these are all
things that i as
a very white person would never dream of
getting away with doing in front of a
police officer it's insane
i i we talked about before why
is it that if it's about systemic racism
i am taught as a white person who's
apparently in this white dominance
culture and i can get away with anything
every time the cop comes to my car when
i get pulled over going 100 in the 45
10 and 2. license and registration in
one hand
yes sir no sir even if he's 19 years old
and a punk
yes or no sir no excuse sir yes or no
sir yes or no sir
that makes that's i'm white supremacist
why yeah exactly why
so i don't know about you guys we talked
about this before but i i got the talk
when i was
when i was younger you know the talk
yeah which one here so
so they're about you know about learning
learning karate and learning
exactly how to fight kids who bully you
how talk about the real talk in the
after showing
when i was little my dad said when you
encounter police
here's what you have to do right here's
how you respond you know
when they're at the door here's when you
get pulled over you got to do turn the
dome light on turn the radio
off stop the car take your keys out put
them on the dash take your wallet your
phone whatever you got put on the dash
your insurance on the dash
hands ten and two and have the window
roll down so when they walk up and they
say license and insurance you go it's
right here officer
and you take it right in front of plane
view and you open it up instead of
reaching in the glove box or reaching
i was told to do that i don't understand
when i see these commercials
there's a commercial they did where it's
like a black father talking to his kid
and it's like
it's time for the talk what you need to
understand about police in this country
and i was like i don't i don't
understand why they don't try to
represent
just poor people in general because i've
been through that you were just saying
the exact same thing you were told the
exact same thing
how you behave with the police i'm
wondering if you guys were ever told
that when you were little
here's how to behave around cops well no
i have i'll let you know
i was told like do that and i was like
okay i didn't know why and then someone
later told me because
the cop is terrified they don't know if
you have a gun
so they're assuming you have a weapon at
all times if you make jerky movements
they're gonna think you're going for a
weapon then it sunk in i was like that's
why
okay yes right yeah so why is it that
i'm told that
why is it that you're told that and then
i act like you were told that dude they
weren't even
so all of my uncles are police officers
or not all of them but three i guess
because
i'm
so of course three of my dad's brothers
became cops nice um
three of my dad's nine brothers his 100
siblings
but no i mean they uh my parents told me
when i was a kid you have to be very
careful when you're interacting with the
police
and they also said this they're like
yeah your uncles are good cops but there
are crooked cops out there they told me
as a kid
don't talk to the police don't even talk
to them when they ask you questions keep
your mouth shut call us
or do they say tell them your uncle's a
cop tell your husband's a cop sometimes
i knew to do that on my own i had those
street smarts i was like hey you know
any of the coughlin's out there or a
police officer
he's like oh yeah he used to work with
that guy here there are a lot of tricks
that that people
people do when they have family in the
police department of the fire department
so i would know about that too so
it's simple so you're saying is there a
lot of tricks people do if they're irish
fire department police one heart but
it's all yeah one of the tricks was uh
was uh just uh i'll just say this if you
know i was to get pulled over
what's going on sorry i'm trying to rush
to the fire department and meet my dad
for dinner
oh you're good to go hilarious
professional courtesy for the
firefighters who are helping us out
things like that we but no no no joke
the police have the stickers the
firefighters have the stickers
and i i simply i'll simplify the story
but i've had incident incidents uh
uh instances with police who have pulled
me over and then when they see the
firefighter emblem they're like who's a
firefighter
it's my dad and they're like have a good
day yeah i mean i'll do it again
stick around the back my dad was a
fireman maybe like who's the [ __ ] both
my sister was a fireman okay well i well
guess what my brother is a paramedic for
the fire department celery
fire person no yes yes i don't know i'm
not sure
she definitely has her pronouns in her
emails now fire person that's her jaw
[Laughter]
firefighters and don't forget animations
post off
postal workers as well do they get
lighter carriers we definitely had a
bunch of litter carriers in our family
but if but if you get pulled over and
you tell the cop you're a post office
worker they let you go no i don't think
that works
i think i think the issue is if you're
like ems paramedics
fire department cop it's because they
all work together
yeah first responders i don't think it's
necessarily about like professional
courtesy
in the sense where it's like oh you work
with a fire department then it's more
like i'm gonna see this guy later on
and we have to have a calm working
relationship if somebody's a family
member of a firefighter you know and
they come and they complain about me or
my badge number
then one day i see the guy and there's
pool it's like oh geez i pulled this
guy's kid over
mad at me right but i i have gotten
pulled over i don't carry i don't put
the stickers on the back of my window i
have fire
fire fighters i have police chiefs in
fact in the family
i've got cops we've got the whole thing
and every single time
abs absolutely yes sir no running
jokes yes sir no sir because telling
telling the cop that you're in the
family
comes after they're comfortable and they
see your hands in plain view
we had a joke because it was so obvious
what you're talking about
to me anyway once you think about it
that we'd be like maybe like license
registration
we'd be like yeah it's right here in my
glove compartment
that's a really bad idea don't ever
actually don't try that one it's a joke
never ever ever and the next day they go
freak lighting so there you go so
like come on guys say perfectly still
assume from the police officer's
perspective and assume that they think
you have a weapon
so now i think we're we are minimizing
some instances in which there's actually
been people with their hands up on their
knees getting shot yes
shot through the doors but we're just
talking specifically
about auto stops and how you can handle
yourself
in an auto stop with law enforcement
yeah and here's the thing there are
psychopaths in every profession so of
course you're going to have psychopathic
cops or even just people with
other illnesses which are untreated who
are or who are just plain evil
who who will um conduct themselves in
dangerous ways or even kill people
but let's let's we still want to teach
people how to behave when they're with
and a lot of it is just common sense but
you want to help people understand like
we could minimize
the number of deaths at the hands of
police each year if folks just
understood this
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you